we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in
yeah just culture show for the first
time it's fantastic i'm 58 year old
liberal redneck we are definitely
nothing coming forth in this country but
anyway man I dig what you're doing keep
up the good fight
things are getting scary out there thank
you and I have a morning thank you yeah
and you know sometimes Pat we get
accused on the program of being
northeast elitist liberals who
discriminate against people on the basis
of southern accents and that is not true
i discriminate against people on the
basis of idiotic political beliefs and
we have endless viewers and people in
our circles that are what you might
colloquially refer to as rednecks and
they are progressive and they understand
the problems of what's going on in our
country and they are out there there's a
popular youtuber by the name of Trey
Crowder who describes himself as a
liberal redneck and I gotta say I agree
with most of what he has to say
all right on the bonus show today
yesterday I filled you in on my vacation
to my birth country of Argentina on
today's bonus show we will hear from
producer Pat about his excellent
adventure across the United States a few
of the things that are involved are
craigslist ride requests yes
Soylent Soylent mecan't auto mechanics
yes and ethanol fuel is that fair it was
a little bit of a preview so those those
aspects and many more of Pat's vacation
on today's bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership to sign up and get
instant access and soon bonus show
availability is coming - patreon as well
patreon.com slash david pakman show